den hawking meinte ja dass wir in 100
jahren die erde verlassen müssten
aber wohin wenn wir keinen planeten
finden könnten wir auf raumstationen im
weltall überleben oder werden hier auch
auf unwirtlichen planeten wie dem mars
überlebensfähig oder gibt es eine ganz
andere verblüffende lösung jetzt
wirklich vom 26 herzlich willkommen
der mensch ist perfekt für ein leben auf
der erde geschaffen skelett atmung
muskeln verdauungstrakt und so weiter
und sofort alles ist absolut perfekt auf
die bedingungen hier auf der erde
angepasst an das nahrungsangebot an die
atmosphäre die gravitation und und und
aber es gibt etwas ganz besonderes was
uns zum einen das leben hier auf der
erde erschwert uns aber vielleicht auch
die möglichkeit gäbe ihm besser als zu
existieren wir sind unzählige in
jedenfalls ein bisschen zu wenig um die
erde im moment zu erhalten aber
vielleicht genug um im weltall zu
existieren
allerdings gibt es dort
rahmenbedingungen die den aufenthalt
erschweren und das sind nicht nur kein
sauerstoff und die lebensbedrohliche
strahlung es ist die schwerelosigkeit im
weltall weiten sich die körper der
astronauten und astronauten aus und
knochen und muskeln bauen sich ab wir
würden also körperlich von jetzt auf
gleich generieren
da sind jetzt erstmal ziemlich krass und
es würde vielleicht auch ziemlich
hässlich aussehen aber vielleicht wäre
es gar nicht so schlimm es gibt genügend
lebewesen auf der erde ohne skelett wie
schnecken zum beispiel aber es gibt noch
ein weiteres ungeklärtes problem im
weltall ab so lauten applaus den leiden
unter augenproblemen von verschwommener
wahrnehmung bis hin zur blindheit einer
ersten untersuchung zur folge damit sich
hinter dem auge um den see nach herum
hirnwasser das dann auf dem sehnerv
druck das könnte der grund sein ein maß
lux könnte also zur erblindung führen
aber vielleicht können wir ja auch
blinkt im weltall existieren
da gibt es nichts zu hören wirklich dort
unser gehör zurückbilden werden wir neue
sinne entwickeln und vielleicht so
strahlung und andere phänomene
wahrnehmen
es gibt keinen sauerstoff werden wir uns
an keinen sauerstoff oder wer wenig wie
auf dem mars anpassen auch hier auf der
erde die plätze lebewesen die ohne
sauerstoff legen die deutsche welle hat
experten dazu befragt kosmologe richard
gott was für ein passender name plädiert
dafür den weltraum zu erobern zitat wir
leben auf einem winzigen planeten im
universum arten die auf einer insel
leben sterben aus zitat ende
da hätten wir zwei planeten auf denen
wir leben könnten dann wären unsere
überlebenschancen deutlich größer außer
ja außer der evolutionsbiologe axel
meyer hat dazu eine ganze
ihre meinung lasst uns versuchen unseren
planeten nicht zu ruinieren wir haben
keine zukunft auf einem anderen planeten
dies ist unser heim hier sind wir
entstanden und hier gehören wir in das
leben ist auch unsere erde durch
zufällige mutation und nicht zufällige
auswahl entstanden der selektionsdruck
im weltall wäre ganz anders kann
sauerstoff temperaturen strahlung etc
menschen würden bevor sterben zitat ende
ja vielleicht wäre es besser dann direkt
ein ganzes raumschiff wie bei der arche
noah der geschichte in der bibel mit
allen möglichen arten von zu packen und
dann mal sehen wer überlebt die chancen
dafür gerade der mensch ist sind dabei
wahrscheinlich eher gering kakerlaken
winter dadurch ganz gut präpariert aber
wollen wir das macht das will auf jeden
fall scheint es mir dass trotz aller
probleme die überlebenschancen hier auf
der erde am allerbesten sinn
wir müssen nur sehen dass wir den
sauerstoffgehalt stabil halten ansonsten
ersticken ihr oder bei mir dauert doch
brennt die ganze erde ab wir müssen nur
aufpassen dass der klimawandel unsere
erde nicht so weit auf dass es hier
lebensfeindlich wird wir sollten unsere
umwelt nicht mit plastikmüll atomarer
strahlung usw
wir sollten uns vielleicht die
überbevölkerung in den griff bekommen
das sind eigentlich lösbare aufgaben wir
müssen vielleicht etwas an unserer
intelligenz arbeiten oder einfach ein
system entwickeln das nicht in noten an
die macht kommen sondern die schlaufen
leute und dann können wir uns ganz
langsam und durchdacht ranmachen
expeditionen ins weltall so auszustatten
dass die mitglieder auch überleben
können und das möglichst lange ohne die
basisstation erde werden wir so glaube
ich aussterben sollten wir das tun
übrigens dann erfahrt es hierbei klick
somit als erste drücken wir dafür
einfach hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht mehr einen auf die glocke
zu geben dann verpasst er tatsächlich
kein einziges video mehr hier geht s zu
den besten videos vom wechsel zwischen
falls ich sie noch nicht gesehen haben
sollten da geht es genauso das band
weiter wie in jugend video dafür einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten würde ich mal
sagen bis dann bleibt dran
auch er gehört dazu nicht